so do you think that the white house
tick tock influencer briefing
was one a good idea
and too well executed
i think so i 100 think it was a good
idea in theory i did think it was weird
so a lot of the people came from gen z
for change which is an organization of
like uh 500 creators i believe i didn't
i wasn't invited through that i was
invited through an individual who just
like helps with youth insights within
the white house um i they didn't seem to
really yeah maybe vet the individuals
there yes they they could like trusted
like oh they're in the reporting realm
or
they have an audience that really trusts
them it did feel a little too
casual i would say like it was very
question and answer but even like uh jen
saki at points was like uh i feel like
comfortable like i can nerd out here
like a little too [ __ ] like
just casual friend-like and obviously
we're there for a very serious reason
and that's what the focus should have
been in the media i totally understand
the initial coverage and the initial
like restraint towards what was going on
but the big focus there was
the
ukraine and russia situation which
should have been more covered in the
media and the information they provided
with us was actually very very strong so
and something that we can talk about
here today too yeah so what did they
share with you that would be news 2
folks uh and it's tough for people i
think because
you wake up and the first thing you do
is you you look up what's happening in
ukraine
and every social media platform is a
very very deep well you could spend
essentially your entire day
uh digging in now so what did they
present to you all and and uh did they
have information that might not have
been uh in the general public yeah so
all the information
from my understanding listening to
briefings and stuff had been
said yeah it's out there somewhere
within the media or within their press
briefings but they kind of not that they
intentionally push three main points but
the three main points that i got out of
it were of course that they want to
de-escalate the situation as soon as
possible the second was that during the
this was now a week ago a week and a
half ago so before
when this press brief when this briefing
was happening the week before that
sent over 250 million dollars in aid
humanitarian military um
and
that was obvious a big feat for them to
do that so quick which they were really
pushing i think now just like five days
ago they approved another 800 million in
aid for military but also the other the
third and kind of the most prominent
point to me was why russia is having a
tougher time with this and it kind of
boiled down to ukraine being more
equipped than they
initially had thought
russia having like logistic and
mechanical issues and also um low morale
amongst the soldiers and i actually saw
that you had quote tweeted a threat
about this and i think that specifically
low soldier morale was very very
interesting to me on the call
and it's really continuing to affect
russia
yeah i i we can dig into this because
the thread you spoke of
struck me as fascinating and you imagine
an army like the russian army would
consist of
people who'd be
ultra loyal
and professional
but it turns out that a lot of them are
conscripts a lot of them are from
poor
small towns
and ethnic minorities
the twitter thread you described which
was from a russia scholar went through
for example a list of wounded
soldiers that had been publicly made
available and over half of the names
were from ethnic minorities and
apparently russia is an environment
where if you do have resources like
let's say a college graduate you can
avoid getting drafted
uh and so the the folks who are being
sent out there are often people who are
less educated less access to resources
uh and uh it's not something that
that is
necessarily being
uh prized or sought after by folks who
have the ability to make a choice yeah
and how the white house framed it during
the briefing i believe also so in the
thread um was kind of important that
these soldiers
didn't even they still don't initially
know like what they are doing there like
what their sole purpose is and many
didn't even know until the night before
that they were going to be invading um
so there's that aspect of it so
imagine that yeah imagine
like you're going to the border and then
all of a sudden you're crossing the
border and then you're standing with
you know with your weapons in front of
ukrainians who are fighting for their
lives and you're like god like i wasn't
even told that we were doing this yeah
because a huge part of like your
willingness to fight is obviously like
your patriotism towards your country and
everything and there's a lack of
transparency there and yeah so there was
that aspect of it and um
it's just insane like these guys are so
young and
and to think of like where we're at with
culture with tech and everything to be
honest like not that a physical war
feels outdated it doesn't in a lot of
means but when it comes to a country
like that that is
depopulating um and just literally
sacrificing those who are yeah poor
positions
it's an insane situation to think about
and it's
extremely unfortunate for all parties
involved right now yeah this is another
part of the analysis which is that
russia is aging yeah it's depopulating
and so they don't have a surplus of
young men
and the young men that are available are
being conscripted
into service they're getting paid in
some cases poverty wages
and so this russia observer
advised trying to
uh let them know that if they defected
that they'd get a certain amount of
money
and that they'd have a pass out
um he estimated that you might be able
to get
maybe 50 000 soldiers to defect which
which would be an enormous uh amount
relative to the size of the russian
force then even those who
didn't leave would be extraordinarily
demoralized by watching their
compatriots just disappear
so i thought this was a fascinating
argument and it felt true yeah it felt
like okay if you are
like a 20 year old kid from some
town in siberia who gets conscripted and
then you show up and all of a sudden
you're you know facing people who are
defending their homeland like if you
have the ability to
maybe uh extricate yourself from that
situation it might be something you
would very seriously consider and and
that would be an enormous win for
everybody yeah i mean we see in the us
too obviously people are flocking to
urban areas and that's also what they
were saying is happening in russia
because you know back a few decades ago
it was mostly yeah the rural families
had a ton of kids and then it was the
rise of like birth control and all these
different things which have just added
up and also is um
has to do part with that depopulation
situation
and
i i mean i don't know if you had seen
this because it was kind it was not
super covered in the media but there was
the zelensky um
deep fake that was really poor quality i
don't did you have did you see that i
just knew that it was a deep fake it was
debunked oh yeah it was like super poor
quality it did get in there like news
articles and like that was on a
prominent um ukrainian news website it
quickly got debunked but it also just it
shows where also we're heading with
warfare and there was um two different
situations in regard to wiperware which
is a very strong type of malware that
with a few files can just completely
shut down um
the software it was found a few months
ago the u.s had found it obviously
because the us has been um
like this has been piping up for the
past year um so the us had found it uh
wiper rare in a railway system in
ukraine which ended up being used for
over 1 million of the refugees to get
out of ukraine and also
microsoft had found this tr trying to um
target the ukrainian financial system
which is insane because they were able
to end up blocking the code within a few
hours but just a few years ago probably
three to five years ago they were saying
that would have taken them weeks if not
months
so the fact they were able to detect
this stuff so early like thank god but
it just shows because of yeah these
depopulating depopulation situations
what we're gonna have to be up against
not because
maybe people would prefer these cyber
attacks but like that's also what
countries are gonna have to resort to
well it's it's clearly the future of
warfare uh and
this particular war is playing out on
social media with
uh one side investing have only the
other side not yeah so if you were to
log on to social media you would think
that ukraine is absolutely crushing
russia because the ukrainians are
posting all these videos about
successful attacks on various tanks and
russians giving up their weapons and
being taken captive and a bunch of other
things whereas the russian side is not
meaningfully investing in uh in this
form of propaganda because on their side
uh there's just much less reward
um
but
there there is going to be
i think an ongoing
uh digital
front to all of these
wars
uh moving forward
well also it's like
growing up and i i still feel this way
and i feel like younger generations feel
this way big text power is more
prominent than that of the governments
throughout our lifetime like in terms of
influence in our day-to-day lives yeah
like what's in our face at all times so
right now
this microsoft situation was interesting
because
what what we see a lot in the media is a
very versus situation between big tech
and the government
but it really needs to be cohesive and
yeah because we see the top tech talent
goes to big tech that doesn't go to the
government which you've actually talked
about often
it's just going to be like how do you
even see the relationship between big
tech and the government playing out
moving forward even the ccp is scared of
their technology companies in terms of
power
well at this point facebook
has billions of users it's more vast in
its reach than any nation state uh and i
think this russian
troop morale situation actually is
really important
on this point yeah so hear me out let's
say you're a nation state you have a
standing military
and
uh unfortunately you're in a time when
like
institutions are faltering and like
loyalty towards let's say the the state
is not what it was yeah and so you still
can script people you know in some cases
you know like frankly they're not that
um excited or even willing but you can
script them and then you you send them
out and so then uh
in the old days i think it might have
been ridiculous to say hey like let's
just try and get them um to defect let's
all like offer them material comforts
for them to come over because like in
most wars soldiers would not have
been open to that yeah because they were
fighting for something that they
believed in
um and or there was like a very strong
chain of command or a whole other things
but like now in 2022 you actually sense
it's like oh that could work yeah you
know like the royalty on the ground
could be completely absent uh and and so
if you give them a a choice they might
take it so there's like this this
fascinating dynamic where
you have
in my opinion
like uh
putin who's trying to adopt like uh an
old-school
war
yeah um and the war is awful and immoral
and like it it's heartbreaking to
imagine all the people that are
suffering and the 10 million ukrainians
have already fled the country and
everything else
um but then if you were to try and
counter it like you shouldn't take for
granted that like that that there's
troop cohesion in the rest of it you
actually should imagine like wait a
minute like that there like that this
might be
um
uh crumbling in ways that aren't clearly
evident and we can capitalize on it
there was another uh editorial that made
a similar case which is that the u.s
should be accepting
defectors from russia and mass
because there are a lot of russian
professionals
who
want nothing to do with this war
and then if they were given a choice to
immigrate to the u.s
that's a real blow
to
russia russia's economy russia's society
and it could also increase the pressure
um on putin and when i read this i
thought to myself
as an american i would gladly accept
russian refugees if i thought that it
would hasten the end of this conflict um
certainly i think most americans would
gladly accept ukrainian refugees i think
that's kind of a no-brainer but then you
think russia and this goes back to the
entire
uh corrosion of these uh uh you know
like notions of
uh of national identity which is like
you know do you think the average
russian citizen is excited about this
war i mean i'm sure some have bought all
of putin's propaganda hook line and
sankara super into it but a lot a lot of
others would want nothing to do with it
and even if you they don't have strong
feelings against the war if they were
offered uh the chance to
uh defect the united states some might
take it purely
because they thought they'd have better
opportunities here
so
i don't know how you feel about that
suggestion but when i read it i thought
like that this makes sense and
apparently the u.s had adopted similar
attacks at earlier points in history
where they were accepting
accepting defectors and refugees well i
also think
we we kind of moved past it but your
point to that thread about um the low
morale and soldiers you had a really
good proposition in regards to that you
were saying to provide them with like
20k in order which is apparently more
than a year salary for that yeah which
is crazy so
talk to that too i found that super
interesting oh yeah so this was not my
proposals this uh this proposal someone
pitched me gotcha it was a government so
as a us government official uh and the
us government official pitched me
because he wanted me to try and uh
popularize it on twitter yeah for sure
because that's one of the things i'm
good for in the world
[Laughter]
well so if there was a random u.s
government official they're like well i
can't put it out there but like let's
try and get someone excited about this
so the proposal was twenty thousand
dollars per soldier fifty thousand
takers it's a billion dollars uh and
given the billions and billions that are
going to be spent and the tragedies
and the loss of life like everyone here
would be like shoot i'd put out a
billion dollars to get 50 000 defectors
like that for sure heck even like
they're probably human beings who would
put out a billion dollars you know if
you you were to get like uh you know
like a
musk or a bezos or someone and be like
hey you want to put a billion dollars to
speed up the end of this war they'd be
like sure
because they would do it for
humanitarian reasons but also probably
because everyone would love them um and
so my mind actually went to how the heck
you'd execute on this it's like if you
even had the billion dollar
uh
fund set up it's like well you know how
do you communicate to the russian
soldiers that this is a possibility how
do they trust it like where do they go
um you know it it wouldn't be
plausible for them to just somehow like
you know arrive in the u.s they'd
probably wind up in
um uh in poland or one of these
countries that yeah that's more adjacent
so
so those are some of the things but you
should know like a legitimate government
official reached out to me and said like
hey this is like something that we
should be exploring it could be
something just he felt yeah um but i
thought that it was an idea that really
should be out there more because
if there's any chance of it working it
would be funds and time well spent yeah
because a huge part also why people are
motivated to fight for their country is
money in itself obviously they're not
being commentated much if the their
opponent is providing that for them and
mixed with the little morale seems like
an easy situation there to move forward
yeah so you know like i mean hopefully
this conflict gets resolved as quickly
as it can but if it it's continuing on
and anyone listening to this is like you
know that's a pretty good idea
you know maybe we should all invest in
time and energy on it trying to to get
this
defector
encouragement
[Music]
you